[Música]
cuando estaba preparando esta charla una
frase en un magazine me impactó
y no vamos
para hacerte la vida más fácil
la vida más fácil para mí para nosotros
para todos la misma vida más fácil o
facilidades diferentes
me hubiera gustado que si no base para
hacer por ejemplo la vida más joven
pienso más poética por ejemplo más bella
más la vida más fácil
pienso en el whatsapp vamos a dar un
repaso a pequeñas innovaciones que no
están de verdad cambiado mucho mucho el
whatsapp por fin dijimos adiós a las
llamadas telefónicas que era una tras
innovar es mirar hacia el futuro siempre
el teléfono fuera nos ponemos a teclear
porque porque es mejor teclear sobre
todo cuando tienes una urgencia por
comunicarte con tu destinatario escribes
un whatsapp y no llamas por teléfono
porque porque el whatsapp es mucho más
rápido la vida más fácil sino para que
si es más rápido
lo podría hacer pero estamos también en
una época donde contestamos cuando
queremos contestar es la vida que uno
quiere plantear al otro así que te toca
teclear y esperar no coges el teléfono
porque porque a innovar no tiene ninguna
marcha hacia atrás no se puede mirar el
pasado en las innovaciones no sí porque
no se puede es todo hacia adelante ya
perdidas llamar no te lo coge pero si
está en línea no te cogen el teléfono
estamos ya en modo tecleo lo siento es
como si en la época cuando aparecieron
los coches hubiéramos dicho ya no puedes
ir en bici todo el mundo en coche igual
nos pasa algo en el mundo digital se
quedó un poco desarrollar el otro día no
pude hablar con mi amigo tuvimos que
tirarnos tres horas un problema grave
por whatsapp tres horas porque no hay
malos entendidos escribiendo no es mucho
más profundo que hablando que nos está
pasando hemos pasado a un modo que será
la vida más fácil no es tan fácil
tecleando y encima como es en paralelo
que puedes hablar con mucha gente estás
abarcando mucho te estás divirtiendo
en esta facilidad no me acaba de
convencer a otros porque veo si mucha
suerte ese mundo
en este caso es como si hubiéramos
cogido la bicicleta para dar una vuelta
pequeña eso sería la facilidad pero de
repente estamos haciendo el tour de
francia todo el el el tour es decir
metafóricamente podemos el coche
no seguimos en bici a veces hay que
pararse para decirle cuando nos conviene
un modo cuando nos conviene otro modo la
estrella del whatsapp son los emoticones
voy a hablar de las emociones para
preparar un grupo
que me encantó unos empleados que
querían que trabajas las emociones para
entenderlas en los clientes y también
entenderlas entre ellos para mejorar
diríamos su salud emocional en la
empresa 250 emociones recabe 7000
movimientos de músculos en todo nuestro
cuerpo variabilidad e innovación que ya
tenemos incorporadas sin buscar más allá
pues no el whatsapp lo ha mejorado
emoticones pones una cara la que sea de
igual un pulgar para abajo para arriba
dos palmadas una bailarina y una para
ella y tienes las 250 emociones
condensadas sí porque emoticones te
permiten significar lo que tú quieras
hay un follón con los emoticones porque
hacemos logística pero netone un mal en
tanto para uno como para un descosido
nos hemos dicho adiós a las emociones
porque porque cada vez más nos
emocionamos menos a través de la
mediación del hekla dora se emociona el
emoticon no te emocionas tú tampoco te
emociona quien los recibe y al final el
emoticones como un playmobil no nos
engañemos lobbistas de bombero o de
vaquero es un playmobil
recuperemos algo de las emociones reales
ya vendrá más tarde que nos está pasando
hay mucha mediación mucha información
mediatizada tanto es así que nos cuesta
contactar nos cuesta tener un lugar
presencial para encontrarnos tienes que
dar con tu amigo con su imposible se
dice mucho ahora lo de lo vamos viendo
te voy contando te voy diciendo si se
contesta a los email y nos vamos viendo
nos vamos diciendo hay un atasco en esta
gran autopista digital termina a veces
en una comarcal porque somos muchos ya
en la m-30 parecía como huevo el futuro
está aquí a toda pastilla y al final yo
muchas de las gestiones las hago
presenciales porque tarda mucho en que
se hagan por teléfono nos hemos vuelto
muy informales hemos perdido algo de una
moral que para mí es lo que me he criado
en los años 60 en parís será la nombró
one o eres puntual
ni ya no hay ya estoy ahí en dos minutos
de la verdad vas a estar en 48 y está
bien para que no pueda en nuestros 48
aprovecha digo entró en la casa del
libro para eso nos tenemos que comunicar
nos hemos vuelto comunicantes de mucha
conexión pero de muchas
pero de poco contenido nos cuesta de
verdad explicar las cosas para que
podamos también una decisión y no
solamente la informalidad las empresas a
ministra se ha vuelto informal es la
innovación la han traducido en disuasión
llama una gran compañía telefónica se
llama para ahora estamos en esta edad es
y llama para darle a la tecla uno se
llama para delegar la teclado se llama
para del de la teca teles a veces no hay
la opción que tú quieres e innovación
pero tú estás buscando la más parecida
ésta sí que ahora se llama para teclado
se llama para así empiezan a aparecer
las muñecas rusas una dentro de la otra
hasta 26 vueltas y al final al final te
dicen algo muy de todos otros agentes
están no es un chiste lo que quiero
decir es que mucho está pasando es esto
fui a hacer una gestión presencial
médico tiene usted no estaba digo por
favor vale ya de chistes malos y estoy
aquí porque lo he intentado viento y
dijo sí
qué está pasando en la transición
digital llamarme a mí que os puedo
ayudar estábamos con el tema de que no
hay personas en el mundo digital todos
nuestros agentes están ocupados pero que
todos los años están ocupados no
digitales cada vez menos personas y lo
vamos a ver más adelante vamos al banco
y te dicen hagan ustedes de su casa
tiene usted internet llegó yo no pero
que hace esta gestión de esto ya lo
puedes hacer desde tu casa ya pero posee
me gusta salir verle a usted ya pero ya
te queda poco y le contesto a él también
te queda poco nos queda poco que hablar
con tus padres
quiero tipo en ese tema algo muy
importante fui a otro va a algo que yo
quería hacer de ese banco y me dijeron
usted no es de nuestro back usted los
martes una hora sólo por la mañana de
ocho y media hora y media cualquiera de
este barco de que yo sea de este banco y
esta gestión no la puedo hacer yo si
usted está aquí no la hace el cajero
automático existe está usted aquí en el
cajero te la hace usted mañana ya no va
a estar
el cajero automático me hace sí pero si
nunca lo es lo he hecho le va indicando
el cajero automático hay ocho o diez
personas cajero automático de hacer
gestiones no le saca dinero y yo digo
que está pasando
los empleados de toda la vida son ahora
los clientes de la empresa en probable
es decir embajadores de la marca y los
clientes de toda la vida nos han metido
a empleados por el artículo 33 lo
queramos o no pero sin sindicatos
tampoco sin el ordenador que no logran y
siguen el plan de formación cómo voy a
entrar el cajero te indica el cajero
vamos a ver los cajeros más sencillos
que hay son los de metro ya está en
metro y en el aeropuerto hay unas colas
que menos mal que hay alguien físico
alguien real una persona que nos puede
ayudar le cuesta la transición digital
imponerse porque no la ha planeado bien
si quieres de verdad que me lo vamos a
hacer me ve mejor cuando aparecemos las
oleadas yo me dije ay vamos a empezar a
echarnos gasolina hay un mundo de
posibilidades el futuro base también
presencial pero sin personas habrá
hamburgueserías que tengan póngase la
gorra entre y usted se fríe su hambre
si miran si es presencial pero no va a
haber nadie con cajeros automáticos y
con no sé qué plan de formación que se
habrán inventado para entonces confío
mucho en el futuro y la innovación de la
humanidad
vamos pero ojo desde casa ya estamos
trabajando muchos trabajando los que
querían trabajar desde casa son labores
de gasta pero los que no queramos
trabajar desde casa ya lo estamos
haciendo trabajar no solamente trabajar
es comparar comparar devolver que te
devuelvan llamar gestionar sobre todo
teclear frase importante innovación
tecleo te creo es una maravilla porque
es súper comprensible qué pasará con
este momento que das a un clic y tienes
el mundo a tus pies porque porque el el
empleado que somos clientes es también
cliente y en la empresa el cliente ahora
es el rey se llama la voz del cliente
escucha auditiva de toda la empresa que
te dice
los momentos de la verdad y los momentos
de dolor se van a acabar queremos saber
qué ha sucedido que ha pasado en qué
podemos mejorar cómo te has sentido no
vendemos productos no vendemos servicios
sino experiencias experiencias y
experiencias dinos dinos la voz del
cliente hasta que tú tienes que decir
una auténtica reclamación reclamación si
queja sí
atención al cliente al paciente si la
voz del cliente se transforma en el eco
de tu propia voz que es así allá ahora
bien ai ai ai ai tengo un problema de
mamá me lo va a solucionar que va qué va
qué va si es así y os pongo un caso muy
dramático siempre que es cuando de
repente la gente más defensora de lo
digital están en esta situación llevamos
cuatro días en el aeropuerto y nadie
ninguna persona nos ha traído agua a
nosotros y nos ha explicado que nos está
pasando la gente más defensora de lo
digital en momentos más duros que en lo
presencial quiénes está pasando
cualquiera cuando tenemos un cerebro en
el límite o sí pero pero el reptiliano
te dice ayuda no hay nada como empatizar
con las personas de verdad los chats vos
lo están intentando les falta todavía
mucho porque porque que alguien diga
estoy aquí no actúan todos los músculos
todas las emociones que por el monte
temático no acaban de llegar qué pasa
qué entonces te dicen dale al clic
y el mundo a tus pies tibás hay trabas
al click y suena cloc cloc cloc si el
premio de consolación es que puedes ir a
twitter o puedes ir a tribales o a que a
echar novio si la palabra es que ha
creado este mundo digital gente
energúmena porque como están las quejas
desaforadas twitter nunca visto que
fuéramos tan maleducados pues sí o sea
que lo digital está trayendo un límbico
un reptiliano muy muy duro para mí
insoportable de verdad usted estamos
soportando unos niveles de moros que
está creando claro la gente envíe un
email ya pasado al otro sitio
simpático se ha quedado la máquina del
café con algo de dinero y entonces hecho
bien que pasa esto me han dado un papel
rellena papel fish y haz la reclamación
la vida más fácil pongan una cafetería
con personas yo mismo quiero formar a
estos canales porque tienes un futuro
para mí si queréis pero hagamos lugares
que tiene que ser de gente tortilla
patata y demás pasamos ya al mundo
médico y estoy terminando no quiero
aburridos el mundo médico todo ha
mejorado por fin tenemos
videoconferencia todos tendremos nuestro
propio médico todos usted usted y
podemos hablar con nuestro especialista
que donde queráis cada uno con nuestro
médico no no hay tantas personas frase
clave en el mundo digital no ven tantas
personas habrá un chat box que ya te
vale y te dirá hoy a que de la opción es
la opción es si a ver lo que le pasa yo
padecí de después dolores abdominales
estaba trabajando en un teatro
importante y no podía faltar entrar en
teatro y es que está trabajando sí o sí
no vale me ha pasado algo con dolores
iba a urgencias un mes y medio yendo a
urgencias aquí haya disfrutado en un
hospital de hospital en hospital no
daban con la clave hasta que por fin
el digo voy a llamar al doctor gasteiz
que es un top un cirujano en aravaca
y le hago una pregunta usted no usa el
ordenador
porque no es que hasta ahora el
protocolo es todo se pasa por el orador
que usted no pregunta yo soy quien
pregunta el médico pregunta usted me
contesta pruebas y todo pasa por el
teclado no hizo algo genial el doctor de
artes se saltó el mundo digital si me
oculto
para mí un mes y medio
el ombligo sigue muy fuerte el ombligo
me dolía ya hemos encontrado que tenía
una hernia umbilical tres días
rápidamente de urgencias y me dijo muy
seriamente en un mes medio si usted no
es nadie le ha pospuesto o consultado ya
viene la gran respuesta que nos está
pasando estamos tan orientados al mundo
digital lo que es para teclear que nos
está olvidando tocar es la metáfora
tocar en la tecla adecuada en este caso
era el ombligo os imagináis que con el
chat me pasa que no me toque a nadie
habrá una mano electrónica tipo t al
minuto que salga del teléfono y me pueda
consultar ojalá que sí para entonces lo
que habrá pasado es que los podremos
operar todos directamente con si
estaremos en online
delmónico lo hace con unos emoticones
vestidos de enfermeros y si les gusta es
todo el problema lo difícil son con las
enfermedades entonces de las más
importantes que hay muchas estamos en
momentos muy difícil pero el estrés la
ansiedad y la depresión que yo las he
conocido las las cesó
órdagos son silenciosas estar en todas
partes
vas al médico y ahí la innovación no ha
hecho nada todavía sin pastillas pero no
no hablo de que cuando vas al médico te
dice cosas como que tienes que
desconectar tienes que dejar este mundo
electrónico tienes que conciliar con la
vida normal afectos relaciones entonces
qué es lo que está pasando qué estrés
depresión y ansiedad vienen por tres
factores soledad falta de relación
emocional y sobre todo super
electrificación el electrónico laboral
que podemos hacer tenemos que conjugar
tengo una frase para terminar cuando era
joven yo decía quiero ir al futuro pero
no a cualquier futuro y sobre todo me
quiero llevar del pasado lo que no
quiero luego echar en falta muchísimas
gracias
las ayudas gracias